[موسيقى]
نعم في الفتره الاولى التي اصبحت فيها
رئيس وزراء كان حزبي قويا جدا كانت له
سلطه تامه على البرلمان كنت قادرا بسبب
ذلك على القيام بامور كثيره من ضمنها
تحويل ماليزيا من دوله زراعيه الى دوله
صناعيه
[موسيقى]
اساسا بسبب قوه الحكومه التي كانت تسندها
اغلبيه مريحه لذلك كنا قادرين على اتخاذ
القرارات وكان البرلمان يمنحها الدعم
الكامل وبسبب ان الناس في ماليزيا كانوا
بحاجه الى العمل وهو ما لا يتوفر بما يكفي
في دوله تعتمد على الزراعه ولذلك قررنا
اطلاق الصناعات لان ذلك يسمح للكثيرين
بالعمل وهو ما وفر الدعم لسياستنا من قبل
الناس لانهم يستفيدون من تحويل البلاد من
دوله زراعيه الى دوله صناعيه
[موسيقى]
غالبيه الدول التي تعتمد على الزراعه لا
يمكنها ان تصبح ثريا لو تتجه نحو الصناعه
فانها ستوفر الكثير من الفرص والعمل
والوظائف لشعوبها التي ستصبح افرع ولذلك
نرى دائما ان تدور الصناعيه اكثر ثراء من
الدول الزراعيه
[موسيقى]